انتقادات تقليد شيرين عبد الوهاب في
برنامج كوميدي وثائقي عن كليوباترا يغضب
المصريين جعفر العمده يربح رهان المشاهده
والتفاعل وهيفاء وهبي تنافس في موسم سينما
العيد اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
اثار اطلاق الاعلان الترويجي لفيلم وثائقي
عن الملكه كليوباترا على نتفليكس موجه
واسعه من الانتقادات في مصر واليونان وصلت
حد الغضب بسبب كون بطله الفيلم سمراء
البشره ووقعوا عريضه الكترونيه تطالب بوقف
عرض الفيلم المقرر في مايو ايار المقبل
واعتبر دكتور زاهي حواس في تصريح لسينام
بالعربيه هذا الفيلم تزييفا للتاريخ
المصري واشار لاصول كليوباترا المقدونيه
قائلا من المعروف ان الملكات والاميرات من
هذه الاصول شقراوات
النهارده
مفيش ادمان عبر ايهاب صالح مدير اعمال
الفنانه شيرين عبد الوهاب عن استيائه من
طريقه تقليد النجمه المصريه المثيره للجدل
في البرنامج الكوميدي ستوديو 23 الذي
تعرضه شبكه ام بي سي خلال شهر رمضان واكد
في تغريده وصفها بالراي الشخصي بانهم
سيسارعون اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه وصرح
صالح في وقت سابق ان حسابات شيرين عبد
الوهاب على مواقع التواصل لم تعد تحت
سيطرتها منذ بدايه العام ووعد مؤخرا
بمفاجاه من العيار الثقيل في حفلها المقبل
في دبي مؤكدا ان المسرح هو الفيصل بالنسبه
للمشككين وذلك في اشاره للشائعات التي
تطال شيرين عبد الوهاب خلال الفتره
الاخيره
وفي اصداء موسم العرض الرمضاني كان مسلسل
جعفر العمده الاكثر تفاعلا في مصر على
منصات التواصل وفي الواقع ايضا الاسبوع
الماضي حيث تفاعل متابعون على نحو طريف مع
براءه جعفر ورصد بطل المسلسل محمد رمضان
جانبا من هذا التفاعل عبر حساباته الرسميه
على مواقع التواصل لكن جماهيريه العمل لم
تسكت اصوات المنتقدين ومنهم المحامي هاني
سامح الذي اعلن عن تقدمه بطلب غير مسبوق
لوزيره الثقافه المصريه بصفتها المختصه
باصدار القرارات بالرقابه لتغيير نهايه
مسلسل جعفر العمده بما يتفق واحترام سياده
القانون وتبيان سوء خاتمه اعمال البلطجه
والتهديدات والخروج على القانون والاعتداء
على المراه واضافه مشهد محاكمه جعفر عن
تلك الجرائم بالمقابل اشاد المحامي المصري
وليد زهران بلفت مسلسل جعفر العمده لما
وصفه بثغره قانونيه هامه في قانون الخلع
بمصر وذلك من خلال قصه سيد اخو جعفر الذي
خلع ته زوجته دون علمه ليفاجا بزواجها من
اخر
من سبع شهور كما يحضر مسلسل المصري تحت
الوصايه بتفاعل متزايد على منصات التواصل
وذلك منذ عرض اولى حلقاته في النصف الثاني
من رمضان وسط الحديث عن استمرار النقاشات
في البرلمان المصري لتعديل قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه ومراجعه عدد من التشريعات
المتعلقه بالمراه وهي الامه دي ان لها شيء
لازمه خالص كلكم خوينا قوي كده عربيا
اختتموا مسلسل سبرليك احداثه الاسبوع
الماضي وهو المشروع الذي لم يكتب للمخرج
السوري الراحل حاتم علي استكماله ليكمل
المهمه المخرج السوريه الليث حجه على اكمل
وجه بحسب اراء العديد من النقاد
والمتابعين ويسلط الضوء بشكل اساسي على
معاناه اهل المدينه المنوره في الحرب
العالميه الاولى والتي افضت لسقوط
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
[موسيقى]
واخيرا من موسم دراما رمضان الى موسم
افلام عيد الفطر في مصر حيث تتنافس عده
افلام على ايرادات شباك التذاكر ومنها
فيلم الاكشن هارلي اسطوره الاسفل من بطوله
محمد رمضان عمر وفيلم الرعب يوم 13 من
بطوله دينا الشربيني واحمد داوود والذي
يصنفه صناعه كاول فيلم 3d عربي بينما تطغى
الكوميدي على بقيه افلام الموسم المنتظر
ومنها فيلم ابن الحاج احمد من بطوله شيكو
ورحمه احمد وسيد رجب وفيلم رمسيس باريس
الذي يعيد هيفاء وهبي للمنافسه في السينما
المصريه